مع طلوع الصباح هذا اليوم الذي هو السادس
وهذه العمليات التي حصلت في الليل مع
العثور على ناجله من جدد هي ستاتي بلا شك
دفع جديد لهؤلاء المتطوعين والمتطوعات
وللمئات من الفرق المنتشره على كل الابنيه
المهدمه في هذه المدينه لا شك انهم ذو
ايام عديده وكل الفرق تعمل بجهد على امل
ان يكون هنالك من ناجين اطفال الرجال
النساء او صغار او فتيا وكانت هذه
الواقعه التي حصلت في المحافظه الاخرى
دفعا لكل الذين ايضا يقفون
ويتسمرون امام شاشات التلفزه يتابعون
لربما عن ناجي واحد يكون في بنايه واحده
لذلك مع بدايه ايضا هذه
التي بدات منذ حوالي ست سبع ساعات الى هذا
التوقيت الذي نرى به الضوء بدا يلوح هنا
في هذه المدينه كانت الفرق تعمل على قدم
وساق بدون ملل وبدون انقطاع فرق تخرج ثم
بعد ذلك تاتي الفرق الاخرى وتؤمن لها
الكهرباء وايضا الالات الثقيله التي تعمل
من دون انقطاع لا شك الى انه يوم جديد
والى انها بدايه جديده بامل على العثور
على ناجينا من تحت الانقاض وطالما انه
يعني تم اخراج بعض الناجين حتى بعد اكثر
من 110 ساعات على مكوثهم تحت الانقاض بعد
هذا الزلزال يعني هذا بالفعل يعطي امل
بانه ربما بالفعل سيكون هناك المزيد من
الناجين